pourquoi j'insiste sur le disposions la
communication en temps réel à partir du
moment où il a été pris la décision de
réorienter les flux
il aurait dû nous aurions dû avoir
l'information en temps réel pour pouvoir
faire preuve d'agilité nous c'est le
stade de france qui nous a accompagné la
fédération française de football qui
prend en compte l'accueil des
spectateurs la préfecture de police qui
nous aide sur l'orientation mais
également la ratp et la sncf pour
orienter ces flux
d'un point de vue très simple à partir
du moment où on nous dit on nous aurions
une information que le flux du rer d et
est poussé vers le pardon le flux du rer
b était poussé vers le flux du rer d en
milieu d'après midi nous aurions dû nous
aurions pu avoir le temps de repenser
nos dispositifs à savoir avec l'accord
de la des opc faire évoluer les forces
les forces mobiles pour couper le flux
de la circulation qui arrive du rer d
vers le rer b mais également pour rom
repenser notre motifs d'accueil sur les
couloirs de palpation et séance à
l'enseignement pour nous qui est
important on a beau construire des
dispositifs pour accueillir les
spectateurs pour les acheminer dans les
meilleures conditions dans les andes
différents endroits où ils veulent
profiter de la finale de la champion's
league avec ou sans billet il ya un
moment où si certaines personnes
prennent des décisions sans en référer
aux autres partis ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est à dire que vous pouvez préciser ce
que voulait dire à travers cette phrase
qui nous n'avions pas et nous n'avons
pas eu l'information que le flux du rer
avait été déviée ratp la préfecture de
police ne vous a pas prévenu que la
préfecture de police non plus n'avaient
pas l'information
alors que nous avons nous sommes
retrouvés nous nous sommes retrouvés aux
alentours de 18h30 à voir un afflux
massif de supporters en provenance du
rer d là où le dispositif que nous
avions mis en oeuvre permettait un
accueil maximum des supporters sur la
ligne rer b la ratp ne vous a pas
prévenu exactement
[Musique]